why don't you open up with me to page
166 and I'm going to transition over to
my nice nearly refilled pad almost got
there
166 now you might recognize this is
chapter six which we started this year
with if you've got your finger on page
166 just flick back a little bit and you
might recognize some of the stuff that's
there algebraic fractions factorizing
expanding if you don't recognize it then
you ought to revise that because those
skills are what we're gonna be building
on for the rest of this topic all right
let's have a look at let's do one like
one scene one sit right down with me so
start with the question it's always
handy to write down what the question is
just so you make sure you get everything
correct
it says G Plus 9.3 because talked with
you I think I think those are numbers
all right so we're always after some
kind of operation we can do to both
sides to get us closer towards the
solution the value of the unknown all
those kinds of things so a good
suggestion is to subtract nine point
three from both sides okay you might
have also heard this sometimes our
teachers will explain it with the
language of taking that nine point three
and taking your over through the other
side and when it crosses the equal sign
it's a positive over here it becomes a
negative over there whichever way fits
the way they think that's fine I like to
say subtract nine point three from both
sides now this line I'm just writing
right now isn't really necessary you can
go straight there but I'm including here
for you so you know exactly what I'm
doing so it's not like black magic where
the next line come from okay the nine
point three is cancel two point two
minus nine point three is I think it's
two point nine
great confidence and of course you can
check on your pack later
alright now that's really easy all you
had to do really to both sides was one
thing the subtraction same queue all you
had to do is one thing for division okay
now before we didn't really need to
include that step to be able to get to
the right answer
okay but here you're gonna have to do
more than one thing okay sometimes some
textbooks are quite this one step
equations and these ones are called
two-step equations because you need more
steps let's see what we can do
you've got a five and a six and I wanna
get rid of both of them so that I just
have a on its own okay which one do you
think I should try and rid off first
yeah okay now how would we get rid of
the five okay how do we get rid of it
it's it's five times too big I've got
five times a day so I could if I'm
multiplying 5 times a I should divide
dividing the opposite in now let's just
see what happens remember if I divide
something I've got to divide everything
right all right we'll do this one so I'm
gonna get 5a on five but there's a sixth
a I've also got a divine six over five
and then there's a twenty six and I've
got to divide that by five as well okay
because both sides are equal I've got to
do the same operation to both sides
otherwise it's not an equation anymore
sorry I take that back it'll become a
different equation if I do one thing one
side not the other is this okay this is
gonna work
5a over five that's just a right now
what do I do
all right what the a on its own right
this this like here I know it's what we
are fractions in it but it looks very
much like this line you've got what you
want plus something else that's what we
want plus something else so what should
I do to both sides I should yeah I
should subtract right so I'll subtract
that six over five if I do it to one
side I better do it to both so on this
side those six over five is gonna cancel
you just get hey what's gonna happen to
me
26 over five minus six seventy five
denominator is the same that's gonna be
20 over 5 and 20 divided by five is just
four it's forever one okay now that's
that's correct yeah by the way before we
move off this I want to very attention
to the fact that this here is the
solution right so when they say
determine the solution of equation this
is it a quiz for you can nonce the
solution because you can take it back to
the first line and like I said like a
key it should unlock it and make it work
watch if as for what happens to this
some left-hand side what's it gonna be
equal to well it'll be five times four
plus six that's 20 plus six sure enough
its 26 so that's how you can know that
you're right okay now that way is fine
but yeah how do I know that I was right
yeah you take your final line this is
what we call this solution right this is
what you were trying to determine you
take your solution and you put it back
in the original line you got that's
that's what this line is about okay you
substitute it in so wherever you see a
instead you stick a four I'll tell you
get it did someone ask something
can I pause you before you do that
because I know that to show you another
way to do it and maybe we can walk
through it together what was your
question okay all right now the question
is why what do we want another way to do
it
I suppose the the reason why I would
want to do it is because I'm just one of
weight fractions where I can okay you
can't always avoid them sometimes you're
always going to get where you don't look
at numbers but sometimes you can let's
start with this first line again so
here's a different way to do it but we
are going to end up on the same answer
okay before we divide it by five that
was what we started with but what else
could we do is a first step was this you
were going to say yes yeah okay good so
you're you're actually what you're doing
is so directly going at that with a sort
of guess and check type approach okay
which which works you'll get the right
answer however the caution with that is
it kind of only works here because the
numbers are nice like it's I can see
what this is always to be equal to right
whereas if the numbers were a bit more
disgusting and hard and work we'd have a
look at some later exercises guessing
chick becomes more and more difficult
and that's why going through these steps
are more reliable method will get you
the right answer then were you gonna
just let's try this okay so let me
repeat in case you didn't hear first
here we divide it by five that's what we
do divided by five that's what made this
line but this time we'll try a different
thing we're gonna subtract six again
from one side and the other so over this
side you have 5a plus six minus six and
twenty six - six I'll subtract it from
both sides what happens to the sixes
they disappear
twenty six minus six is just
now you've got the fire to get rid of
right but we can do that the way we did
it before by dividing right sir I'm
going to divide that by 5 divide that by
5 over this side it cancels and we get
the same answer okay now I do like this
second way a bit better you can even see
on the board it's shorter okay
partly because it avoids some of the
fractions like I said you can't always
but have a look being that you've got
these two equal ways like they both get
the same answer okay try and figure out
which one's quicker all right